[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue
j - 2 avant l'élection présidentielle le
premier tour numéro spécial de parler
brains au bonjour katia bonjour michael
et deux invités nous accompagne pour
commenter cette semaine bruno cautrès
bonjour bonjour chercheur au cevipof
spécialiste des comportements politiques
en face de vous frédérick michaud vous
êtes directeur des études d'opinion
d'opinionway et merci d'être avec nous
merci à vous bonjour alors cette fête
campagne elle a été marquée par un
événement ce jeudi soir c'est un nouvel
attentat qui a frappé la france qui a
frappé paris notamment les
champs-elysées un policier tué deux
autres de personnes dans un état grave
l'assaillant a été abattu première
question bruno cautrès est-ce que selon
vous il peut y avoir un impact sur le
scrutin de dimanche
alors bien sûr c'est toujours une
question qui est sensible de savoir si à
la dernière minute un événement
dramatique peut venir bouleverser une
élection et on a tous en tête le
souvenir du 21 avril 2002 et notamment
des tout derniers événements qui est
justement été sur le thème de la de la
sécurité ménard moi je pense qu'il faut
être assez prudent sur cette question
ça peut sans aucun doute peut être
renforcée des tendances qui sont dans
l'électorat déjà si par exemple les
candidats qui incarne qui communique
beaucoup sur la question de la sécurité
sur la question de la loi et l'ordre
sont déjà en train de remonter
bien sûr que ça ne peut pas alors
s'appeler favoriser quand ça peut bien
sûr aller dans le temps dans ce sens là
mais de là à bouleverser la donne
les équilibres de cette campagne
électorale sont maintenant assez
stabiliser quand même depuis un bon
petit moment et pourtant la campagne et
les riches en événements frédéric
micheau vous partagez cet avis que ce
type d'événement n'aurait pas d'un
d'impact de nature à bouleverser l'issue
du scrutin mais cole peut modifier à la
marge
oui je partage totalement on voit bien
qu'il ya deux candidats qui pourraient
en tirer parti dans une petite mesure
évidemment marine le pen qui prospère
sur les thématiques but sécuritaire
et puis également françois fillon qui
avait produit un ouvrage vaincre le
terrorisme islamique est effectivement
voit bien que ça pourrait un petit peu
amplifier la dynamique électorale dont
il bénéficie depuis quelques jours et
alors au contraire pour celui qui le
favori des sondages on en parlera tout à
leurs manuels macro juste à la marge est
ce que lui au contraire ça peut
défavoriser historiquement au début de
la campagne était plutôt en retrait sur
les thématiques régaliennes il a gagné
en stature il a acquis une stature
présidentielle
il est crédité aussi d'une forme
d'autorité
donc ça peut évidemment jouer un petit
peu mais sans doute beaucoup moins qu'en
début de campagne où les français
aujourd'hui ce que selon vous il ya une
crainte pour le vote de dimanche menaces
terrorisme menace sur la sécurité est ce
que le scrutin et menacé
je pense que tout le monde y pense bien
sûr et tout le monde savait que même si
la question du terrorisme avait été
faiblement présente dans la campagne
électorale c'est vrai qu'on a eu très
peu de candidats à venir alors tous les
candidats ont fait des propositions dans
le domaine du recrutement des forces de
l'ordre des policiers militaires
mais la question du terrorisme elle a
été fortement dans les codes dans les
programmes est assez faiblement dans la
campagne
donc évidemment tout le monde pense que
malgré cette faible présence si quelque
chose devait se passer dimanche sa vraie
alors à ce moment-là peut-être un impact
absolument majeur sur le déroulement de
la journée électorale
c'est la première élection
présidentielle qui se tient sous le
régime de l'état d'urgence avec
peut-être des gens qui ont
éventuellement peur d'aller voter
ça ça compte ça crée un bien sûr est un
climat qui déjà de toute façon et au
climat dans l'opinion qui est déjà assez
pessimiste assez anxiogène
donc évidemment ça ajoute un élément
supplémentaire d'une tonalité de la
campagne électorale qui globalement
quand même a été une campagne assez peu
prospective la france qui regarde vers
l'avant et assez peu de candidats qui
ont été dans ce registre là il ya
beaucoup de candidats qui ont été sur le
thème que la france est menacée que le
mythe manquer les menaces et
culturellement qu'elle connaissait
toutes parts dont bien sûr ça ajoute un
élément à cette tonalité de la campagne
on va prendre concrètement le pouls de
l'opinion si je puis dire avec quelques
sondages publiés juste avancé
andrée d'histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
frédéric micheau vous avez publié une
dernière étude avant le scrutin
opinionway orpi pour les échos radio
classique
on va avoir tout de suite ce premier
tableau on était emmanuel macron en tête
du premier tour avec 23% d'intentions de
vote un point devant marine le pen a à
22 3e françois fillon puis jean luc
mélenchon on voit bien quatre candidats
dans un mouchoir de poche pas de favori
et 28 % d'indécis tout est possible
toutes les combinaisons sont possibles
oui effectivement on voit bien que la
quatre candidats aujourd'hui serait en
mesure de se qualifier pour le second
tour de l'élection présidentielle c'est
inédit
soula sous la vème république
généralement vous avez toujours deux
candidats qui en fin de campagne se
détache et apparaissent comme les deux
candidats favoris on est là
véritablement face à une configuration
électorale sans précédent
vous croyez vraiment aux jeux à 4 c'est
pas quelque chose qui est la puissance
des médias
si on prend sérieux que les sondages
donnent des estimations et que ces
estimations elle ne représente pas à la
perfection ce qui va vraiment se passer
le jour du vote et qu'il est d'une
certaine manière la nature de
l'estimation d'être peut-être un peu à
côté de ce qui se passe du jour du vote
oui on est obligé de reconnaître que
statistiquement les biens quand on dit
que le matériel est que notre état 22 ça
peut être très bien que tous les deux
sont à 21
est ce que ça vous inquiète de vous
tromper sur certains candidats comme par
exemple emmanuel macron ça nous inquiète
de nous tromper d'une manière macron sur
marine le pen tout sur françois fillon
sur jean luc mélenchon également on voit
bien d'abord la configuration inédite on
vient d'en parler mais on voit aussi une
recomposition du paysage électoral qui
est à l'oeuvre notamment évidemment avec
la position centrale d' emmanuel macron
alors justement emmanuel macron vous le
mettez en tête des intentions de vote
pour les estimations 12 pour des
tendances du deuxième tour est ce que
votre intime conviction c'est que pour
son retour on est marine le pen emmanuel
macron ou pas du tout à voir ce carton
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas intime
conviction
il me semble que plusieurs second tour
sont sont envisageables un second tour
qui opposerait françois fillon en marine
le pen est également envisageable et
même un second tour avec emmanuel macron
face à françois fillon également
je n'exclus pas pour autant la présence
de jean luc mélenchon au second tour
même si elle paraît peut-être un petit
peu moins probable que celles des trois
autres candidats dont le match à quatre
produits quand ton choix mais quand on
voit les tendances cercle ce qui est
vraiment intéressant dans l'est dans les
sondages alors certains critiques
l'avalanche de sondages peut-être qu'ils
ont en partie raison mais en tout cas ce
qui serait intéressant dans l'avalanche
de sondage c'est que justement ça permet
de regarder les tendances et les
sondages sont d'autant plus intéressants
qu'en leur temps en les regardant
tendance si on voit que quand même les
deux candidats emmanuel macron et marine
le pen depuis de nombreuses semaines
maintenant sont deux candidats qui sont
un peu au dessus des autres ça veut pas
dire que nécessairement et se qualifie
pour le 2e tour mais ça veut dire que
dans l'état de l'opinion en france ce
sont deux candidats qui ont clairement
marqué cette campagne et qui sont parmi
les quatre candidats de sérieux très
sérieux candidat pour le deuxième tour
l'état de l'opinion c'est aussi s'être
proportion visiblement importante
d'indécis mais aussi d'abstentionnistes
on parle souvent de pourcentage mais en
nombre d'électeurs ça pourrait donner
quoi on parle souvent d'un des six ou
d'indécision au sens large sans prendre
la précaution de définir ce que c'est en
fait ça renvoie à différents phénomènes
ya d'abord ce que vous indiquez c'est à
dire l'hésitation entre le fait d'aller
voter ou le fait de s'abstenir
et là on a à peu près
10 à 15% des électeurs inquiets dans
cette hésitation dans hick ont pris dans
les tout derniers jours avant le scrutin
et puis ensuite il y à des candidats des
électeurs par donc ils savent qu'ils
vont aller voter mais qui ignore pour
quelle candidats et des électeurs qui
ont choisi un candidat mais qui peuvent
encore changer leur choix jusqu'à la
dernière minute
beaucoup parmi l'un des six jeunes
ouailles à deux questions de boue dont
on n'entend que beaucoup parlé pendant
cette campagne votre cas chez vous y
croyez ou pas alors le vote cacher c'est
un des mythes auxquels on aime croire
c'est à dire dès qu'il ya quelque chose
qui nous a qui nous a échappé et qu'on
va avoir une surprise de dernière
seconde mais il peut y avoir quand même
dans cette élection pas du vote cacher
mais ya pu avoir des acteurs un peu en
mode sommeil
c'est à dire les électeurs de françois
fillon qui ont été versées mais voilà
qu'on était un peu assommés par ce
qu'ils ont appris sur leurs candidats
préférés et qui peut être commence à se
dire mais finalement c'était notre
élection elle était imperdable c'était
pour nous c'était à notre tour et donc
ils vont peut-être se réveiller mais ça
représente une partie de l'électorat de
françois fillon potentiel qui est quand
même parce sa dominante notre cracher
votre cas chez vous y croyez wauquiez
chez j'observe que c'est surtout un
argument de campagne utilisé par
certains candidats ça avait été le cas
lors de la primaire de la droite et du
centre d'un argument utilisé par nicolas
sarkozy notamment s'il y en avait pas
fonctionné ça n'a pas fonctionné
s'il ya un vote cacher ça renvoie
justement à cette décision électorale
très tardive en 2012 conçu pour cent des
électeurs s'étaient décidés le jour même
du scrutin et 15% dans les tous derniers
jours
ça fait quand même un quart de
l'électorat qui prend donc une décision
électorale très tardivement et dernier
terme donc non pas aux ordres beaucoup
entendu parler vote utile vote utile oui
alors le vote utile ce qui est
intéressant est très important de
rappeler s'équiper ailleurs deux types
de vote utile vote stratégique y en a un
qui consiste à choisir un candidat qui
n'est pas votre candidat préféré
mais de choisir le candidat qui pour
vous se rapproche le plus de votre
candidat préféré qui d'une certaine
manière limite les dégâts pour vous et
puis il ya une autre forme de vote
stratégique ou utiles qui lui est
inversée c'est à dire qui consiste à
revenir vers le candidat de son coeur
parce qu'on considère que le candidat de
raison lui déjà qualifié pour le
deuxième tour donc autant réexprimé sa
préférence idéologique
par exemple si on avait des électeurs
d'hénin
elle macron qu'ils maîtrisent de son
maquereau est qualifié pour le deuxième
tour
mais finalement je reviens vers benoît
hamon ça peut changer soit justement des
coûts oui ça peut changer les choses
alors là on entre évidemment dans des
calculs qui prennent en compte toute une
série de deux paramètres et qui sont
propres à chaque électeur
alors on va voir comment ont tenu les
candidats routine fini cette fin de
campagne et on va commencer par emmanuel
macron qui a sorti de sa carte maîtresse
cette fin de semaine il s'est affiché
avec jean yves le drian en meeting
france ogoula elsa mandingue avalisant
suivi accusé d'inexpérience par la
droite emmanuel macron s'affiche avec le
ministre de la défense dont l'action est
saluée quasi unanimement et manuela
qu'on veut rassembler les français et
leur redonner de la confiance
là dans le domaine qui me concerne plus
particulièrement sur la sécurité sur la
défense une logique très forte une
termine à sion très
sensible objectifs ajouté de la
légitimité sur les questions de sécurité
alors que la menace terroriste pèse sur
l'élection présidentielle pas de prise
de parole lors du meeting pour le
ministre toujours en exercice mais il
est salué par emmanuel macron un hommage
tout particulier à jean yves le drian le
leader dans marcheront également un
hommage appuyé aux forces de l'ordre
n'oublions pas de rappeler que l'ancien
chef du raid la rejoint dans son
discours sécurité donc mais aussi
défense de l'europe et attaques contre
marine le pen les propos indignes de
madame le pen qui a affirmé qu'avec elle
la france n'aurait pas connu les
attentats qui ont ensanglanté
ces propos ne sifflait pas ne sifflait
pas convaincu et chaque jour nos
concitoyens qu'elle ne peut pas relever
le pays
quel enfermera battez vous dans les
urnes avant la prise de parole des
manuels macro un autre soutien populaire
avait fait son entrée à la tribune sur
l'hymne européen
l'écologiste daniel cohn bendit je suis
submergé par le fait que ce jeune homme
en deux ans et réussi avec vous et pas
lui tout seul a bouleversé le paysage
politique en france
des soutiens appréciée par les militants
le bas d'abord des vieux briscards un
peu d'élus ça va lui faire mal chance de
gagner ces dépenses qui va pas hélas
crédible aux yeux des gens dans un
mouchoir de poche avec ses trois
adversaires dans les sondages emmanuel
macron entend faire campagne jusqu'au
bout avec deux meetings prévus vendredi
à rouen et arras
donc cette fin de campagne c'est aussi
l'heure du bilan pour cette campagne
bruno cautrès est-ce que vous jugez que
manuel macron a fait une bonne campagne
ou pas on peut difficilement nier qu'un
phénomène macron de grande ampleur qui
s'est passé la réunion bien sûr il a
réussi
retournons il ya un an quand il crée en
marche
au fond tout le monde dit ça va se
dégonfler ça pourra jamais marcher c'est
est attendu autour d'eric il n'a pas
l'expérience on peut pas créer ex nihilo
quelque chose et au fond emmanuel macron
c'est le symptôme avant tout d'un truc
qui ne va pas dans notre vie
démocratique de quelque chose qui ne qui
ne va pas qui est cette vie démocratique
du mal à se renouveler
lui sans aucun doute il a été
suffisamment adroits suffisamment
talentueux pour et bien s'engouffrer
dans cette brèche mais cette brèche
était déjà là avant la séquence que nous
venons de vivre avant la séquence il ya
dix ans il déjà la friche vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse vous avez
perçu à quel moment qu'elle est ce
phénomène macron si vous l'avez perçu
oui alors on voit bien que dans la
campagne présidentielle
il ya deux phases qui concerne emmanuel
macron est un véritable décollage dans
les intentions de vote à partir du
ralliement de françois bayroux qui vient
crédibiliser sa candidature et permettre
aux candidats dans marche de se détacher
de françois fillon il a fait une bonne
campagne
aujourd'hui il est en tête des
intentions de vote ccc proprement
spectaculaire ce qui a accompli emmanuel
macron il a vaincu toute une série de de
résistance le scepticisme de beaucoup
d'observateurs il était aux alentours de
10 15%
il y a à l'automne 2016 et aujourd'hui
il est aux alentours de 23 20 4% en
première position partie de 120
technique souris dessiné par ailleurs et
par ailleurs il a aussi diversifié la
sociologie au tout départ du phénomène
macron la sociologie de son électorat
potentiel est clairement une sociologie
de centre-droit mois gérer analyser ça
de près on voyait très bien que le
profil était un profil des lecteurs de
type udi d'ailleurs souvent plus
sudeikis modem et puis progressivement
on a vu qu emmanuel macron se densifiant
en élargissant son son périmètre son
image plus présidentiel etc d'érable il
a aussi diversifié sur tout et surtout
il est arrivé à attirer une part
extrêmement important de l'électorat
hollande 2012 la moitié c'est ce qui
explique qu'il est aujourd'hui un seuil
très important et que résistant aux
événements de la campagne alors on va
parler de marine le pen qui elle décline
ses thématiques
bien connue identité patriotisme
l'immigration terrorisent la présidente
du front national qui stagne un peu dans
les sondages et mais qui a durci le ton
en cette fin de campagne rabique à
barrière de sécurité policiers
lourdement armés et palpation le
renforcement du dispositif de sécurité
n'a pas entamé la détermination des
militants du front national on a
réfléchi avant de devenir ma pole s'est
dit il faut pas non plus rentrer là là
[Musique]
avant cession
on a vu que c'est sécurisé en passant
tout à l'heure nous devrons maintenir
mais il ya beaucoup de monde on est bien
fouillé ce qui est normal avec ce qui
s'est passé sur coup hier
il ya de quoi perdre très attention au
lendemain de l'arrestation à marseille
de deux hommes soupçonnés de préparer un
attentat
les thèmes de ce dernier meeting sont
tout trouvés pour la candidate frontiste
l'immigration et le terrorisme
l'occasion également pour marine le pen
de dénoncer le silence de ses opposants
sur le sujet il a fallu que les actes
terroristes se multiplient partout en
europe pendant la campagne il a fallu
que la menace terroriste serait à vide
dans l'actualité pour qu'il daigne du
bout des lèvres
contraint et forcé effleuré le sujet un
retour aux fondamentaux avant de lancer
un dernier appel au vote dès dimanche
prochain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
selon le dernier sondage harris marine
le pen serait crédité de 22%
d'intentions de vote juste derrière
emmanuel macron qui l'a dépasserait 2 3
points à la proche du premier tour de
l'élection ce que l'électorat de marine
le pen se cimente au contraire s'érode
puisque vous c'est d'abord et avant tout
un électorat qui a la foi est très
mobilisée aujourd'hui l'électorat du
front national est sans aucun doute
celui pour lequel la le lien entre se
sentir proche du parti et voter pour le
ou pour les candidats du parti le plus
étroit c'est un électorat par ailleurs
qu' un socle sociologique c'est pas
seulement un socle en nombre de 2
d'intentions d'autres mais c'est un
socle sociologique très résistant d'une
certaine manière mais marine le pen
aujourd'hui c'est pratiquement le seul
électorat qu'une vraie sociologie avec
vraiment des zones de force qui sont des
bastions sociologique les milieux
populaires
les travailleurs pauvres les précaires
les intérimaires la halle a vraiment
marqué des points
depuis qu'elle a pris la présidence du
front national et donc c'est sans aucun
doute cette sociologie qui peut lui
permettre de se qualifier pour le
deuxième tour parce que c'est un cetain
ce comme une sorte de vraiment de deux
bastions et ce bastion permet de
résister aux fluctuations de la campagne
elle un peu peut-être en fin de campagne
difficile mais néanmoins l indésirable
mobilisés et très derrière
elle était très haut dans les sondages
il ya quelques mois quelques semaines
encore vu qu'il y avait un léger
tassement est ce que la grande surprise
de dimanche prochain ce sera l'absence
de marine le pen au deuxième tour à ce
serait une surprise dans la mesure où la
plupart des sondages annonçaient sa
qualification pour le second tour n'ont
pas de manière accidentelle comme en
2000 quasiment sa faible mais de manière
certaine
depuis plusieurs mois et même depuis
plusieurs années effectivement ce serait
une véritable surprise mais vous votre
intime conviction c'est quoi à nouveau
sa qualification paraît paraît probable
pour les raisons que vous venez de
rappeler on voit bien qu'elle a une base
électorale qui est très solide et qui
est très mobilisée derrière elle mais
rien n'est fait alors on va s'intéresser
maintenant à celui qui est considéré
comme le troisième homme de cette
campagne c'est françois fillon il
s'adressait justement aux électeurs du
front national on l'écouté depuis
quelques semaines ce terme d'identité
est apparu dans la campagne
présidentielle
on commence à se demander de quelle
france nous parle monsieur macro
monsieur mélenchon on découvre
subitement la france open space de
monsieur macro et la france bolivarienne
jumelée avec cuba de monsieur mélenchon
et tout à coup nation patrie racines
culture identité ces mots qu'on croyait
tabous ont imposé leur nécessité
donc sur ces questions d'identité est ce
que là françois fillon va chercher des
électeurs qui étaient enclins à voter
plutôt pour le front national et donc
marine le pen
est-ce que c'est sa seule façon de
pouvoir remonter dans la dans cette
course
alors la question d'identité c'est une
question qui a été très fortement mises
en valeur par nicolas sarkozy en 2007 et
en 2012
la difficulté de françois fillon dans
cette campagne c'est qu'il ne parvient à
récupérer environ 60% des électeurs qui
avaient voté nicolas sarkozy en 2012
une partie d'entre eux
malgré le soutien de nicolas sarkozy set
malgré deux soutiens nicolas sarkozy une
partie d'entre eux voteraient pour
marine le pen et une autre partie serait
séduite par emmanuel macron donc en
activant réactivant cette thématique de
l'identité
il cherche à faire revenir ses électeurs
de nicolas c'est d'autant plus
intéressant ou paradoxal que françois
fillon fait partie de ceux qui au début
de sa démarche présidentielle disait au
fond moi mon truc c'est surtout que
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas été au bout de
ses idées dans les réformes socio
économiques en particulier il s'est
arrêté au milieu du chemin sur les 35
heures et c'est donc c'était vraiment ça
le coeur de françois fillon son livre
fer qui était le message entre les
lignes
nicolas sarkozy lui il a dit l'a pas
fait donc moi je dis et je vais faire et
puis on a vu un françois fillon qui
s'est retrouvé complètement empêtré dans
ses affaires et dans les airs beaucoup
d'un d'abord dans les dents dans dans
ses affaires et qui est obligé de
revenir aux fonds versés thématique de
la sécurité vers la thématique de
l'identité où pourtant il avait lui-même
dit nicolas sarkozy l'a surtout effet ça
puis l'a pas fait les réformes socio
économiques
donc on voit qu'il est un peu obligé en
fin de campagne d'essayer de rattraper à
part sa base finalement c'est ça ben oui
une partie de sa base qui l'a un peu
quitté qui trouvent que et qui était
important dans la primaire
sans aucun doute on avait vu une
primaire avec une base qui étaient des
traits caractéristiques d'une droite à
ces identités qu'il essaie de rattraper
sa base mais en tout cas elle n'agit pas
forcément son nez
lectorat attention c'est ce qui est très
frappant quand on regarde la courbe
d'intentions de vote de françois fillon
tout au long de cette campagne
elle est quasiment plate avec très peu
de variation plus bas ils descendent et
18% au moment des affaires justement ou
plus haut à 21%
voyez très faible amplitude et il ne
parvient pas c'est sa marge au botteur
jusqu'à présent c'est ce qu'on a c'est 5
ans mesurés et ne parvient pas à élargir
ce socle électoral et en même temps fait
preuve d'une très grande résistance
alors on va parler des petits candidats
c'est à dire ceux qui sont crédités de
peu d'intentions de vote c'était
l'occasion pour eux de convaincre une
dernière fois et parmi ces petits
candidats il ya jean lassalle qui était
en meeting le candidat des années était
à brison saint innocent en savoie
écouter quelques extraits de son
discours vous avez pu se faire
harmoniser la candidat du terroir
atypique qui se démarque par son franc
parler qu'apporte une candidature comme
celle de jean lassalle
elle est utile alors si le candidat qui
s'inscrit effectivement dans quelque
chose qui est assez intéressant qui est
le retour de la question du territoire
la ruralité de pas seulement de la
ruralité m'entends tu quand particules à
la ruralité et lui témoigne qu'au fond
il ya une partie des électeurs qui sont
des électeurs à peu à la périphérie par
rapport aux grands centres de décision y
leur porte parole
et chez lui ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est les éléments de
cohérence entre sa propre biographie et
puis ce message jean lassalle c'est ce
candidat que la marché à travers la
france qui était la rencontre des
français c'est celui qu'avait fait cette
grève de la faim dont un candidat qui a
toujours voulu montrer qu'il était aux
côtés de sa circonscription électorale
et des électeurs de la circonscription
donc on le retrouve là tel que l'ont
mené jean lassalle c'est un tout petit
segment de l'électorat les contres
mais voilà vote que vous pouvez aussi
quantifier il serait crédité de combien
selon alors nous nous le mesurons à
hauteur de 1% dans la tête revoir
tension de vote ont soit 1 % ça peut
paraître faible mais quand on se disait
aux petits candidats est ce que c'est
important si on le rapporte à l'ensemble
de l'électorat ça représente quand même
un certain nombre de ces combien bon
sens de voix le corps électoral français
ses 47 % 47 millions pardon j'avais
estimé mail à steve ince et qu'on est
vraiment dans le cadre de ce qu'on
appelle une candidature de témoignage
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs vous parliez de la
tentative de séduction des ruraux on
voit bien que le candidat ou la
candidate plutôt qui capte le vote des
ruraux c'est marine le pen et et même au
delà dans ce qu'on appelle le périurbain
liés à la toute une france qui se sent
abandonnée en tout cas à l'écart des
grands centres de décision et des
grandes métropoles qui elles sont très
bien connecté avec la mondialisation qui
votent prioritairement pour marine le
pen
maintenant on va parler d'un autre
candidat françois asselineau lui parle
de l'europe écoutez je propose de sortir
de l'union européenne de l'euro et de
l'otan dé mon installation à l'elysée
par la mise en oeuvre immédiate de
l'article 50 du traité de l'union
européenne et de l'article 13 du traité
de l'atlantique en c'est ce que l'on
appelle le fric site je suis le candidat
lui faxer françois asselineau on le voit
un peu partout quand on est en voiture
notamment il ya beaucoup de défis
voilà on a d'abord connu comme le
candidat des des affiches beaucoup
d'observateurs pensaient qu'ils
n'auraient jamais les 500 signatures
pour se présenter les a eus se présente
donc il essaie de tirer parti de
l'occasion d'être présent dans la
campagne présidentielle sur le thème
européen le le problème c'est qu'il ya
pas de majorité sociologique en france
pour le fric si tu sais si les français
sont devenues critiques qui sont en
demande de deux sens sur la question de
l'europe
ça veut pas dire que les français
souhaitent que la france sorte de
l'union européenne et lui il n'y va pas
de main morte puisque c'est la sortie de
l'euro de l'aura de l'otan des thèmes
qui sont des thèmes difficiles il
faudrait normalement expliquer comment
ça c'est pas simplement je vais faire
siffler et à nouveau c'est très
difficile de faire exister cette offre
programmatique à l'ombre de nicolas
dupont aignan 4% deuxième candidature à
l'élection présidentielle et surtout à
l'ombre de marine le pen qui
qui utilisent ces thématiques de la
sortie de l'euro depuis plusieurs années
ils vont faire les frais du vote utilisé
je puis dire aussi c'est oui c'est un
championnat bien sûr oui très clairement
alors dernier de la liste sur votre
liste notre sondage jacques cheminade
qui fait lui aussi campagne sur l'europe
alors certains disent on applique la tri
de 58 ans sortira en europe et c'est
très bien comme ça
et ben moi j'ai repris le discours de de
gaulle
vous savez sur les cabris bien entendu
on peut sauter sur sa chaise comme un
cabri en disant europe europe europe
faisait le bol mais cela n'aboutirait à
rien et cela ne signifie rien c'est vrai
c'est pour cette faut sortir de cette
europe telle qu'elle est n'oublie dire
dans le même discours de gaulle disait
du moment que je suis français je suis
européen étant donné que nous sommes en
europe et je dirais même que la france a
toujours été une partie essentielle
sinon capitale de l'europe
par conséquent bien sûr je suis européen
donc c'est cette nouvelle europe
il faut créer quels sont les critères
déterminant l approche du scrutin pour
un électeur sur quoi ils vont faire leur
choix
alors le vote il répond à plusieurs
logiques il ya une première logique est
une logique de très long terme
on ne vote pas au hasard on ne vote pas
comme un jeu de loto comme un jeu de
hasard est d'abord et avant tout quand
on vote on exprime son appartenance à
une multitude et bien de milieux sociaux
à une certaine idéologie le territoire
dans lequel on a été élevé compte aussi
donc on est accompagné dans l'isoloir au
fond le jour du vote par toutes ces
variations ces déterminations de très
longue durée
et puis elle rôle de la campagne
électorale on a pu découvrir des
candidats et enfin il ya l'ultime moment
c'est celui de la prise de décision
c'est celui où on est en ce moment et
c'est celui dans lequel vient se nicher
cette question de l'indécision
donc c'est une sorte de 2,2 le vote est
un phénomène qui est une sorte de
sédimentation temporel différents temps
qu'ils se rencontrent et le jour des
élections et bien tout ceci replier dans
l'unité de temps et de lieu du bureau de
vote
il nous reste à peine quelques secondes
simplement dimanche ça va changer
quelque chose pour vous que les bureaux
de vote ferment une heure plus tard
entre à change fondamentalement la donne
c'est une vraie contrainte pour les
instituts de sondage qui ont une heure
de moins pour produire les estimations
des résultats du vote donc oui c'est une
vraie contrainte technique qui peut
potentiellement affaiblir la qualité des
estimations électorale les docks
amateurs on n'est pas sûr de savoir non
pendant qu'ils faisaient leurs demeures
travail en tout cas nous on vous donne
rendez vous dimanche
émission spéciale à partir de 19 heures
sur les antennes des chaînes
parlementaires très bonne ces deux
programmes sur lcp public sénat
ciao
[Musique]